let's give shot okay I really love it
because it's that combination of things
that you'd or phrased in ways that just
unusual enough just to make it a bit
difficult to think when weights this
talking about so this is 6i question 19
it starts off nice and gentle it says
can you work out what is the sum of this
AP the natural numbers from 1 through 24
okay now because I have the first term
and the last term which would be am I
going to use it on to a plus L right so
how many terms are there in this series
25 for what do different face example I
have to put it out in one two there it
is right and our first and last terms
are 1 and 24 okay I'm going to be a
little bit naughty and right across the
page whiteboard right 24 1 2 is 12 1
plus 24 is 25 25 512 is 300 so there you
go partay we've obliged we have no idea
what to that but it's done not too
difficult next part they give you this
series and they actually want you to
you're required to show what it's sum is
equal to that they provide your
expression for the son but we don't mean
it like it's not hard to work out what
the sum of these two is news it's it's
not obvious from start what to do that
right but it's a pretty simple AP once
you sort of unpacked what might you do
be that every single term is divided by
n now if I'm gonna multiply by n then
I'll have to divide by n as well right
to maintain the sequence okay I just
want it to be simple and I want it to be
easy to see what ap is hiding under the
EP right so I'm gonna factorize okay
let's take a factor of one out of em at
the fun you see why this is a sensible
thing to do okay so what I'm gonna get
left to eat
an AP very similar to the one I headed
Potter right so I'm going to get one
plus two plus three plus all the way up
until n so that's the only difference
it's an indeterminate length okay here's
the wonderful thing right this is an AP
that I know really well
I can use my n on to a plus L form to
work out the sum of this AP do you agree
with that are you staring funny what are
you looking at what are you tweet
everything is all right okay
so I would continue okay how many turns
are in this AP
in terms right so therefore I will have
end on two pairs right when I do my n
onto a plus L but Evan is literally n
okay one of my first and last term's one
and so pretty simple there's some
canceling up that happens there cancel
cancel so I get n plus one or two if you
have a look at question 30 that is
required of a paint now it's time to get
your skates on he was the point they
give you this series and what they want
is you can see it goes on a remote goes
forever but what they want is the
partial sum which has 300 turns in it
they want the sum of the first 300 terms
okay
now part of what makes this question so
interesting is you look at that and you
think what series is that look what is
it even like it's so strange
it's not this it's not this right
because you can see the denominators
keep changing do you notice that okay
you look carefully but it's it's is this
so relationship here for example if I
look at these numerators I see one two
three one two three
but then for some reason it stops and
then you get one two three four okay now
what's going on what's happening here
can you see that this is actually a
series that's made up of a whole bunch
of series do you see that let me try and
make a little will obvious okay
here are all the terms with denominator
one yeah you came back how many terms
are there with denominator to the next
sheet numbers there then I've got the
numbers with denominator three and then
I have their numbers with denominator 4
and I could keep going if I want okay
are you happy with that
alright now I want the first 300 terms
in the first three have you checked but
this is kind of tricky because I don't
even really know what the 302 tone is
right I can make some guesses and I will
make some guesses in a second but it's
not immediately obvious right like when
you're trying to follow a pattern here
for instance what what have you turned
to my god now I've got eight terms right
out of the eighth term here no so I
again no Tim yeah ten times what's UT
for the tenth term here is 4 out of 4
which is 1 okay but the night so is 3
quarters like how do i how I predict is
because I'm sure is not gonna write out
400 okay okay so I wonder how the codes
are turning in your head right
how can I work out what this series is
the whole thing how can I put it
together now you should be suspicious
should be immensely suspicious
especially when they give you a question
of an early part like this which seems
like it has nothing to do with anything
except for the fact that has everything
to do with what you're doing all right
what point of commonality do you see
with Part A and Part II I see 300 terms
not that I can't then you yeah alright
so let me let me get that down and then
hopefully the connection will start to
unfold for you right especially being it
up online is number how many terms are
in there in this series here I've got
one right that's the first partial sum
then you've got sukhiya then you've got
3 in the next I guess you could call
them to kind of like rupees if you like
and then I'll have for right now what I
want to do is I want to add up a bunch
of these groupings such that what about
up all the groupings I total to 300
right but I've already done that it's
the first line I heard on the board
right how many groupings will I need
such that the first group is 1 then 2 3
& 4 such that when I add on the last
group it gives you 300 and the answer is
20 for the last screw this is the size
of the first group then the second group
then the third group if my last group is
of size 24 and when I add them all up
this is the number of terms I will have
you see it you see what's going on okay
so now I know where is this thing going
to end because it actually doesn't go
forever for what we're interested in to
get the 300 terms
what will the last grouping it's gonna
be a very good it's the grip that has 24
terms in it right which of course is
going to have a denominator of 1 to 24
right so it's gonna go one over 24 2
over 24 3 over 24 all the way up until
good okay so now we've defined the
series that's a big step ok we can go a
little further in fact we need to go a
little further cuz I still don't have I
just write this two more terms
I still don't have actual values here
right yeah if you use the number very
good fantastic so finish see that each
of my groupings which I pull it in right
each of them is of the form that the
sequence the series in Part B want you
see that okay so for instance um they're
there right is the first group 1 over 1
it's got one two and there's the second
group it's got 1 over 200 2 over 2 so 8
equals 2 and there's the third group and
if I put 25 over 24 there that would be
my last group okay so therefore each of
these
to all groupings is equal to that you
see that
so therefore chucking a big equal sign
let's have a go at this I don't really
need to worry too much about the first
series because I don't have a suit okay
I could now start evaluating but instead
I want to form a pattern because once I
get a pattern then I can see what's
going on so n plus 1 on to what's in for
this there are two terms - right
what's the next term it's gonna be
emphasis on on - again but this time the
N is three terms right so it's going to
be forever - now of course I could
simplify that but I'd rather not because
it makes a little more obvious what's
going on right I don't need a fourth
term to establish my series but I might
as well write this is 2 over 2 this is 3
over 2 this is 4 over to get 5 over 2
where will I end remember it's n plus 1
right so the last time would be 25 1 -
yeah that's what we're doing because I
need to know to find this sum of a
series I need to know either what's the
first last or I need to know which I've
just found out right through this by
following that pattern say to you so
that I know what the pattern is doing
and how many times I've got all those
kinds of things okay you see in this
world now I know there are 24 terms
yeah so that's how I use it now what am
I going to do here I mean this is that's
to get a bit simple right how can we use
what we already know to our advantage
let's see I'm going to do the same thing
here that I did up here right so
everything I can divide by to take out a
factor of 1/2 so what I'm left with is 2
plus 3 plus 4 plus all the way up until
5 ok pretty fine yeah that's my last
time
and then I think you can do your same
and onto a plus L in there how many
terms are there in here we just
established there are one two three four
five six Sept 24 times right so this
will be 1/2 times M on to watch out for
what your ends are because n changes all
the way through right times they're a
plus L first in the last term which is
27 which from memory I think should be
hundreds easily for that okay happy do
you see how we did it and peel the
layers back on something which is the
beginning right now that I put these
brackets in you can't unsee them provide
there there's i/o it's obvious the
structure but before you see them it's a
bit trickier so my tip is colors think
about what structure is it you can take
advantage of